لقد بلغت سن الـ 51 أثناء الوباء وأدركت
تمامًا أنني كنت
أدخل الثلث الأخير من حياتي
والذي أعلم أنه شيء كئيب
لأقوله ولكن في نفس الوقت كانت هناك
هذه الاكتشافات المذهلة حول ما هو
الدماغ الأسود.  Box
قادر حقًا وأحد أكبر الأشياء
التي تعلمناها هو أنه يمكنك زراعة
خلايا دماغية جديدة في أي عمر
للعلماء الذين غيّروا كل شيء
أردت إنشاء كتاب العمل هذا مع
إدراك كامل أنه على الرغم من مقدار
الضرر الذي قد تتعرض له  أو ما مدى
الاهتمام الذي ربما لم تكن قد توليته بعد من
عقلك ، يمكنك البدء في إحداث
تأثير كبير في إنشاء دماغ أكثر حدة ،
لذا إليك بعض
النصائح المفضلة التي أعتقد أنه يمكنك
تجربتها اليوم
أحد الأشياء  نحن ندرك أنه
يمكننا صنع هذه المادة الكيميائية الرائعة حقًا
في أجسامنا تسمى bdnf ، فأنت
لست بحاجة إلى تذكر أن هذا هو ما
يسمح لخلايا الدماغ الجديدة هذه بالبدء في
الإنبات فعليًا وتنمو السؤال هو
كيف تحصل عليها لا يمكنك تناولها  لا يمكن أن
تبثه ، يمكنك فقط القيام بذلك
وأفضل طريقة للقيام بذلك هي من خلال الحركة
الآن شيء واحد أريد التأكيد عليه هو
أنه غالبًا ما يقال أن ما هو جيد
للقلب مفيد أيضًا للدماغ
وهذا صحيح  ولكن عندما يتعلق الأمر
بالحركة بدلاً من النشاط الهوائي المكثف ،
فإنهم يجدون أن
النشاط المعتدل يميل إلى أن يكون أكثر
فائدة ، لأنك ما زلت تصنع
الكثير من هذا المعجزة ، لكنك
لا تصنع الكثير من هرمون التوتر الذي
يحارب هذا النوع في الواقع  أن كلا من bdnf
يمكن أن يكون جيدًا ولكن أحدهما أفضل للقلب
والآخر أفضل للدماغ ،
كان هذا شيئًا آخر فاجأني إلى حد ما
عند التفكير في
التغذية في الدماغ عندما يتعلق الأمر
بالسكر ، فهناك شيء مهم حقًا
يجب تذكره عندما يكون لديك الكثير من  السكر
في مجرى الدم يمتص جسمك
كل تلك السعرات الحرارية الزائدة على شكل دهون
لا يستطيع دماغك فعل ذلك ببساطة ، فعندما
يكون لديك الكثير من السكر في مجرى الدم ،
تتوقف مستقبلات الدماغ نوعًا ما
نتيجة لذلك يمكن أن
تفرط في جسمك و  تجويع
عقلك في نفس الوقت
[الموسيقى]
لدينا هذا الدماغ الكامل لاستخدامه
ونستخدم أجزاء مختلفة منه ولكن في معظم
الأحيان نستخدم حوالي خمسة إلى عشرة بالمائة منه ،
وتسعين بالمائة من وقت
الاكتشاف هو البدء في استخدام تلك
أجزاء أخرى من الدماغ إذا كنت تقوم بعمل
ألغاز الكلمات المتقاطعة ، فهذا يشبه إلى حد ما أن
تصبح أفضل في معرفة
بلدتك الصغيرة الصغيرة
مساحتك الصغيرة ولكن إذا كنت تريد حقًا البدء في
تسخير قوة الدماغ ، فيجب عليك
القيام بأشياء مختلفة
بشكل مفضل.  الأشياء التي تقع خارج
منطقة الراحة الخاصة بك قليلاً
والأشياء التي تتطلب
نشاطًا حركيًا لليدين من نوع ما ، بدأت الرسم
بيدي اليسرى أثناء الوباء ،
استخدم عقلك بطرق مختلفة ، وهكذا
ستحصل على أكبر قدر من
الضجة  من أجل جهودك على المدى الطويل ،
لدينا جميعًا قدرًا معينًا من التوتر
في حياتنا وبالنسبة لكثير من الناس
الهدف هو إخماد التوتر للتخلص
منه وما ندركه عند
النظر إلى الدماغ هو أن هذا ليس
هدف جدير أو مفيد حقًا نحتاج إلى
التأكيد عليه ، وهذا ما يجعلنا ننهض من
الفراش في الصباح ، ونؤدي
عملنا كل هذا ولكن المفتاح هو عدم
التعرض لضغوط لا هوادة فيها ، لذلك إذا
زاد التوتر عليك أن تجد وقت التوقف
خلال اليوم  للسماح لها بالعودة إلى أسفل ،
يجب أن تبدو هكذا بدلاً من
مجرد البقاء منتشيًا الذي يبدو أنه ما
يجعل الدماغ أكثر صحة